tonight on P Borg un sensor Captain sat
Tom Moore became a global hero during
the pandemic his family stands accused
of tarnishing his legacy tonight
exclusively they respond we should have
done it in a different way when I first
walk in the first thing I see is a
luxurious ble that's got nothing to do
with Captain Tom it was never intended
to be the captain Tom Foundation
Building for anything like that
articulate how it's been utterly
devastating and how much were you I was
paid £18,000 for that the only question
is whether you should have pocketed the
cash good evening from London and
welcome to a special edition of Da
uncensored a world exclusive interview
with the embattle family of Captain to
Tom
Moore tomorrow will be a good day he
said and like him it was just what we
needed in our darkest hour Captain Tom
Mo was a hero of the pandemic he won the
nation's Hearts by walking a 100 lamps
of his garden in lockdown raising 38
million at NHS
Charities the whole world loved him the
late Queen knighted him and when his
foundation launched it looked set to
become a philanthropic Force but the
100-year-old war hero died with coid in
2021 now his family Stand Accused of
failing to protect his legacy and
enriching themselves using Captain Tom's
name Hannah Ingram Moore is the
Charity's co-founder his daughter she's
been criticized for her salary as well
as big payments for public appearances
the charity commission is investigating
conflicts of interests between the
foundation and family businesses most
incendiary of all they added a home Spa
to a foundational building in the
grounds of their listed home and they're
fighting plans to tear it down the
family insists they've done nothing
wrong they want to help the world in
Captain sat's good name but is that
already too
late Hannah Colin Georgia Benji thank
you very much indeed for sitting down
with me Hannah let me ask ask you
straight off about why have you agreed
to do this interview what do you hope to
get out of this I think um P you know
you've been on this journey with us
since almost the very beginning back in
those early days of 2020 in lockdown
when the world um started talking to my
father and um of course with all the
love that comes with something like that
and there really was love Global
Adoration of him and everything that
he'd done to give hope to the world
there was always an underbelly of hate
but we um we lived with it because in
fact what he was doing is he was giving
hope to the world and all we wanted to
do was support him to do that what did
that underbelly of hate look like it
never genuinely occurred to us and maybe
that seems foolish but it never occurred
to us that anyone could hate um a
100-year-old man walking up and down to
support the NHS and the family behind
doing everything they could to support
him and so when it first happened I
remember it was Benji who said to me Mom
you might not want to look on your
Twitter I think it was and um I said why
and he said because it's horrible and I
think the shock the Deep shock that
people were saying
um you'll have to bleep this out if you
need to they were saying bit should die
um she should be yeah she should be
jailed for um harming the elderly but
she's got a cattle prod taking her
father around the garden hope the whole
family get Co and die including him and
it went on and on and on and on um one
day I we were doing 30 interviews a day
not because we wanted to but for love
and for Hope and we got a call and um I
think you said Hannah can you come
quickly we've got an interview to do I
was in my workshirt that had the company
logo on it so I ran to do it to be with
my father and the hate that came after
that there she is trying to manipulate
um life to get her business in the
spotlight it had never been anything of
the sort so we even Colin and I sat
there and thought maybe I have to stop
being a director of our business because
maybe the campaign of hate is going to
be so damaging we'll never recover from
it I mean I've got some of the emails
that you were receiving you kept them
and col these are some aimed at you and
some are aimed at uh to the foundation
but you know this one just a sleazy pair
of Pon slime parasites fleecing people
on the back of an old man's heroism he
must be turning in his grave at the
disgusting parasitic leech called his
daughter hope you all get coid and
disappear for good this is someone who's
put his actual name here and his email
right I mean when you see that Colin
what are you feeling I think it's just
disgusting I mean it's it's been
horrendous this this was to be clear
this was in July of this year year after
all the media coverage of the stuff
that's been going we will come to the
specifics about that but just this
reaction and it goes on I mean there's
so many of these Captain Tom a true
gentleman inspiration to Millions his
daughter a disgusting parasitic pwnl the
morals of a dead Slug and so it goes on
I mean I can't really believe what I'm
reading here I know I mean i' I've this
is your wife they're talking about yeah
and I know and I well my family yeah and
we've I've spent many years in rugby
clubs and Heard lots of language but all
in one sentence and to the and very
personal and individual to particularly
to Hannah uh it's just totally
unacceptable and though you try not to
read
it you can't avoid it well this one is a
letter addressed to you Georgia yeah and
you know you're 14 years old I have a
young daughter nearly 12 so I can't even
imagine what this must have been like
but it was to Benji and Georgie
are you aware that your parents your
mother more than your father is a vile
greedy bleep a vile diseased greedy
greedy
bleep with a copy of a of a newspaper
story about what's been going on when
you received this what did you think at
first I thought it was from my friends
saying oh I'm so excited to see you back
at school and stuff and then my dad took
it and like oh don't read it just don't
and then I said oh no I really want to
read it and then I was like oh that's
ridiculous why would someone say
that I mean the idea Hanah that someone
would take the trouble to write a letter
to your
daughter here to this to this
address as her mom what does that make
you feel oh it's devastating this is a
pretty pink envelope with unicorns and
hearts on it deliberately done so that
we wouldn't see it so that Georgia might
might pick it up innocently and open it
you would think it was a lovely little
letter from her friend like candy blush
on the back handwritten handwritten you
would absolutely never think in a
million years of the content would be
like it was but something when it
came I remember saying wait because
something about it because mostly you
know that uh children Georgia's age
they're speaking on Snapchat um so so
there aren't many letters that come and
when I saw it I immediately said to
Colin wait I think you need to open it
but have you had death threats as a fan
yeah yeah you all immediately said yeah
yeah absolutely specific death threat
some you know some to her some to
Georgia and me some went to Dad to all
of us individually together everything
they set up there's a forum and in all
honesty I I tell you these things
because I've been told that they're
there I don't look because I I think if
I looked I well you wouldn't be able to
cope that so there's a forum that they
found where they were um a group of
whatever they do on the forums that um
they were all discussing how they were
going to come and kill us all in our
beds um with pitchforks and and Hammers
and um firebomb our house yeah we know
from what's happened to Holly Willoughby
yes in the last week that actually some
of these people can be deadly serious
right it's scary have you reported these
threats to the police yeah has anything
happened because of it of it and under
the harassment act we've got a a log
which has going all identified so if it
becomes persistent we can we can or they
can then follow that
[Music]
up last time I saw you all was at when I
did live stories my show with Captain
Tom and it was honestly one of my
all-time favorites and he was amazing I
mean yeah yeah 100 years old I managed
to sit through like a two-hour record he
was so funny Charming intelligent had
great stories everyone loved him um it
seems you know there's a picture of him
with the queen here pict you here yeah
yeah from the interview but also one of
when you all went up for his Knighthood
I mean that moment when he got his
Knighthood from the queen that must have
been I'm I'm sorry P but that was even
better yeah that was even better yeah
but I mean that was an amazing thing and
and you know what does it feel like as a
family Hannah for you all to to be there
and meet the queen and have her tap him
on the shoulder it was magic and I
remember us being in the car going down
and um I turned to him and said nervous
feeling okay and he went not at all in
the way that you could imagine we felt
our roles were just as his backup um
what was amazing though and I think that
people didn't know is that the queen had
asked to see all of us um um so we
weren't there in our ordinary sort of
behind the scenes roles we were there to
stand with him what did she say to you
guys the queen you remember yeah yeah
she talked to you about dogs or and
school as well yeah about what year I'm
in how I'm joining it online learning it
was like being a grandmother talking to
a grand she was the nation's grandmother
yeah but she saw him and I in some of
our photos you will see it she saw him
and it was two people from the same
generation their eyes met and she smiled
in a honestly it was just amazing to see
him kned at the age of a 100 and it was
I I think he if he died the next day he
had been happy um it meant everything to
him what's incredible is that that all
happened because just outside here the
famous walk because he'd been unwell he'
had a bad fall he' broken some ribs and
hurt his lung and so on and he decided
to try and get a bit fitter and was
going to walk a 100 laps and you were
going to give him a pound a lap I think
right and you just told the local paper
because he was also about to turn 100
you thought it was a nice story in the
pandemic and then suddenly it gets
picked up by the local media then the
national media I remember I was on Good
Morning Britain and we interviewed you
guys and then I was on the first week
and then suddenly this thing explodes
what is it like for you guys that here
as a regular family you'd lived with
your grandfather for 13 years here
leading a perfectly normal under the
radar life and suddenly you've got the
entire world willing on your grandfather
with this walk I think it's incredibly
difficult to put it into words because
genuinely it was the first weekend of
lockdown this was something as part of
his rehabilitation program that you know
being the yorkman himself always wanted
to do and he was really ill really ill
to a point we we generally thought we
would lose him only a year prior and he
had that gr he had that determination as
a yorkman to go and do this but it was
the first weekend of lockdown everyone
was a bit stuffed on what they were
going to do and as much as he gave hope
to us when he started that walk he he
evidently gave it to the nation but as
we crept up the interviews every day 30
interviews a day raising £3 million
pound a day it it just becomes utterly
surreal and Georgia I mean this is your
granddad right and suddenly the whole
world knows who your granddad is that's
weird it is quite weird even some of my
teachers she was like wait isn't that
your granddad I'm like yeah it is that's
so cool and you must have been
incredibly proud of him I I was really
proud of him because he achieved so much
in a little amount of time before uh he
died yeah you took him to barados and it
got a bit of criticism hand of this that
because he was he died two months later
and turned out he'd had pneumonia I
think on the trip to Barbados and then
he got coid and the pneumonia probably
reduced his ability to fight the co and
it very sadly killed him he was over a
100 so you know this was not an
unexpected shock as to think for the
family that he would at some stage uh
pass but the criticism that came your
way that you should never have taken him
to Barbados uh that that was a
contributing factor to his death what
what do you feel about that it was his
dream um Barbados if you go back in time
he was interviewed I I can't remember
which newspaper said what's on your
bucket Captain Tom and he wanted to go
back to India um he wanted to jump out
of an airplane attached to somebody and
a parachute um and he wanted to um go
and watch The Cricket in Barbados and
Barbados tourist board and their prime
minister were quick Off the Mark and
this was back in um very early very
early yeah in in 20 in in the in the
second week of um his walk so he said
yes please he'd love to go we just
couldn't go because we were in multiple
lockdowns finally we found a period of
time when we could all go and we were
all invited and his dream was to go uh
to go and see the cricketers in Barbados
you got a cricket B over there signed by
some amazing oh yeah West Indian legends
Gary s Garfield soers Wes Hall Joel
Garner Gordon Greenwich I mean I'm a
cricet fan these are some of the Great
cricket ever play the G were you
concerned about him not being physically
able to make the trip not at all in fact
we had um doctors to to check and they
said go Captain Tom enjoy it be happy no
one knew how long he was going to live
we also didn't know that he had silent
pneumonia nor did they um but
nonetheless we we got on the plane and
then we have photos of him on the plane
it he he was having he was treated like
a king we'd had to take tests Co tests
before we left M when we arrived we were
quarantined immediately so we were then
put in um a place where there were CCTV
in the house that we were in we could
not go outside until we'd been cleared
Again by another test so we know that um
he was healthy and that we didn't break
lockdown rules and that we were also not
coid positive I mean the criticism and
it was the first time I'd really seen
that was well you all got a great
holiday out of it too so all right for
Tom to live his dream but you're all
getting in this lovely free holiday in
Barbados because it was a pandemic
people annoyed perhaps that they
couldn't travel whatever you know you
know the argument that came that way did
you consider any of
that we we paid the first week was at
the guest of barbad tourist board but
after that we paid for it it was paid
for by us so it wasn't free when I
interviewed the St is he loved all the
attention he loved it he loved being a
star he lived his life anonymously for
99 years and suddenly he's a superstar
and he loved it I I knew that um but
what it showed me was that there was now
a rising appetite for looking at ways to
attack you as a family he died several
months later I would imagine after all
you'd all been through to lose him even
though he was 100 years old still a
massive BL and it must be even now very
strange to be in this house without him
yeah we were a family of five you know
for 13 years one of the things that
we've never quite been able to do is
probably to grieve as a
family um because we grieved of the
world um but we didn't really because
there was so much going on after he
passed um that we didn't really have the
chance to just close the door sit down
quietly reflect think about all the good
times that we had with him we did of
course but not as not without being in
the the glare of the media and
everything and what were your last words
with your dad oh it was amazing actually
it was Benji and I were there um and we
we stayed with him and he was really
with it to to probably the last few
hours yeah and um there's some things of
course I can never repeat because he was
quite funny and and sometimes
quite cheeky um but I ran down a list of
people who he'd like to speak to of
course I can't tell you the answers to
any of this but I'd run down the list
and he'd say definitely
not I hope I wasn't one of
those and um and then he'd say okay yes
to that one yes to that one absolutely
not to that one and um so we we had a
bit of fun right to the end what were
the last things that you just you
chattered to with your grandfather H as
said I keep as much of it private as
possible but for him I think he was just
saying go go do your thing you know be
proud of what you're doing continue
George and me continue doing amazing
things and how proud he was of all of us
and that for us was such a special
moment because we really um we really
had lived with him close and he was a
really tight part of the family you must
all miss him Georgia terribly playing
character I miss him terribly cuz after
Sports we would go chat about sports how
if I got really angry he would say what
why would you why did you get angry
we'll sort it out practice and practice
we'll watch something on the TV to sort
out sort it out we'll go and paint
something just to make you forget about
[Music]
it welcome back to unsensed and my
exclusive interview with the family of
s Tom MO
you always said tomorrow will be a good
day and Hannah it's been a difficult
number of days for you as a family
actually since then and a lot of it is
centered around these issues surrounding
the Captain Tom Foundation the charity
you set up in his memory um and various
other parts uh of the pie around there
so let's go through some of this let's
start with this building because this is
the Captain Tom Foundation Building and
as we sit uh you're waiting to hear in 2
or 3 weeks as to whether this has to be
knocked down or not let's go back to the
start of this when you first applied for
planning permission for this what was
the purpose what did you want this to be
so you have to go back a little bit in
time um people will have seen when he
was walking that we had um a small above
ground pool on the driveway and when um
he had fallen and broken his hip and um
was Terri ill he came home and wanted to
rehabilitate and he'd said I fancy um
walking up and down inside the pool we
never going to get you in there that was
the foundations of well maybe we can get
one of those pools where you can walk
against um the resistance of but it
never happened because of coid so this
started way back this wasn't just
something we did there was an intention
to have that for him and then what
happened we had 225,000 birthday cards
arrive m which are stored um in London
at at quite a large cost to us on top of
that thousands of things thousands of
things that are stored in another three
other plac I've seen boxes and boxes of
stuff and that's just the stuff tiny
amount that's a fraction of it so it was
also taking over our house and taking
over rooms in our office so we said look
why don't we reenter it so that we can
have somewhere to put all of those
things because also those cards 200
25,000 birthday cards we haven't
recycled them or got rid of them because
we feel they have a place in as part of
the nation so this isn't doing things
selfishly it's about how can we preserve
what did you want this building to be to
be yeah just purely that some storage
multi-purpose to be able to put some of
his things in it some of his memorabilia
we also wanted to um have it as a
community building so that we could help
some of the local aging population maybe
we could have some Pilates classes up
here maybe they could come and do what
my father couldn't do and walk up and
down in the resistance pool and also
have meetings um because this is the
perfect place when talking about the
Legacy that my father's left of that
incredible Legacy of a world without
aism and okay so that's the original
plan and that gets approved by the
council yes uh but then you make another
submission and this time you wanted to
add a spa pool which is what I've Just
Seen around the corner which which is
you know it's quite a big Spa pool um
why why did you need to have that well
that was the historical part so we we
bought it because we talked about doing
it with my father but he's already given
the heat a DI by the time you did this
so why did you want to add the spa here
as a family because we because we wanted
it as part of that Legacy and because it
was a nice thing to do I think that was
a mistake I think that was always going
to attract now the original plan yeah I
mean I've been walking around here and
the memorability is incredible from the
The cricet memorability Joe Root's shirt
Michael Bourne's England Blazer you know
to the pictures here and incredible
stuff but it's very hard to argue that
you need a spar pool to pay tribute to
your father and it's very hard to argue
that whatever the original plan in your
heads that he would be able to use it
obviously once he died that argument's
gone too I just don't think you should
have done The Spar pool and I think
that's what angered the public because
they're like how does that add anything
to the memory of that looks like you are
giving yourselves as a family a nice
little treat but you're using the
Captain Tom Foundation umbrella to
justify it that would be what I would
say to you yeah and I think look
everyone can look in hindsight and our
original application the the name was
never intended to be the Captain Tom
Foundation it was supposed to be the
captain Tom building it got lost in
translation and we take responsibility
for that completely the original
application does name check Captain Tom
Foundation a lot it it does so it looks
like the
foundation is somehow approving of this
but it turned out they were not
approving of it no and this building was
not to do with the charity it was where
we could use it for charitable do you do
you accept that you should have at the
very Le least told the foundation and
sought their approval for it if you were
going to use the name of the foundation
for the application I think we
absolutely didn't tend intend it to be
the captain Tom Foundation it and it
shouldn't have been and we should have
checked it and we should have made sure
it didn't say that so we completely
accept responsibility for it because the
purpose of the building was
multi-purpose for office use for
meetings and when you look at the part
where we've covered that pool
we could have left it uncovered we could
and and hindsight says that we probably
should have um so we have to accept that
we made a decision and it was probably
the wrong one I think you just you
played into your critics hands yeah
right Colin I just think that when I
came in I thought I wonder how big that
is you know what it's pretty nice it's
something most people can't afford it's
an expensive luxurious thing has really
nothing to do with uh Captain Tom or his
Legacy or anything actually it's purely
just a nice thing for you to have as a
family but you were applying as the
Captain Tom Foundation to do it that's
what Ang was certainly a statement from
the foundation said they were not happy
about that they weren't involved but
secondly just public opinion we accept
that we accept it we you know we were
caught up with trying to get the the
building to do what we wanted it to do
um we should have called you know we
wanted to leave the name of Captain Tom
here as a legacy and we should
have done it in a different way and
without any doubt and you know we we've
suffered as a result um a lot of the
locals Benji they've also been angered
by this they also think the building
itself is a bit of an eyesa but it's
just an aesthetic detail of this y but
do you I mean do you agree that the The
Spar thing has just goed people into
thinking maybe not what you intended at
all but that actually you were
benefiting from this yeah what I hope
people understand as well is we did not
use charity money for this it may have
you know hindsight we shouldn't have
called it a capon Foundation Building it
slipped through the net and that is
responsibility we take but never once
did we use money from the foundation and
I hope people can can understand that
part of it and also the ISA thing
granted when you build something people
are going to have objections to it and
what I hope they understand is it's also
not finished we haven't finished it I
think no I think look I think Hannah I
think the thing about this is if it
genuinely was a kind of Museum to your
father I think people would accept that
they might want some tweaks to the
design or whatever it may be I think
it's that has been the problem and I
think it's also it's a grade two listed
building your property here I have one
of those I know how difficult it is to
get anything onto a grade two listed
site and the again the criticism is that
you use the Captain Tom Foundation name
repeatedly in the application almost
making it very difficult for the council
not to approve it and they did approve
it and then you add this other stuff
which is clearly not part of any kind of
Museum that's really where we are with
this aren't we I think so and and again
we what we talked about was to um have
charity meetings here it was never
intended to be the captain Tom
Foundation building where it would house
staff or anything like that but look
hindsight is is a wonderful thing and we
should have been more careful and we
should have done this
[Music]
differently have you offered to get rid
of the barle we're we're in the appeal
of process of appeal so we are going
through the process but would do you not
think it might be Colin just good Optics
to say regardless or whatever the
council say that was a bad idea we're
going to get rid of it at the moment
where we're at is if we lose the appeal
the whole building has to get demolished
right um and obviously any compromise in
between that we'll have to have a look
at but that is that is the position and
that would be a great
shame one neighbor told D I knew Captain
Tom quite well he would have hated
what's gone on here what do you feel
when you hear would um you know we
thought we had really good relationships
with the
neighbors um it's been unfortunate that
they taken a a stance they've um but we
would we wouldn't want that to happen
you know the village has been fantastic
to us um and really you know there are
certain people in the village that have
gone way over and above and beyond and
you know we've done an awful lot for the
village as well over the years and we
you know we were quite sad to see all of
that and we we wouldn't want it and
maybe you know they wouldn't want it
either Hannah who's paid for this
building we have we have all personal
money all personal money so not a penny
has come from any money that was raised
in your father's name not one penny
that's category no there'll be no paper
tra there'll be no paper tra so it's
entirely your money see that's why again
I just ask you one more time because I
think it's important regardless of what
the council decide with this appeal and
they may decide to raise the whole thing
in which case this becomes a moot point
but if they don't do you not think it
would be a good idea to get rid of that
sparle honestly I think that how I feel
about this whole thing now is just
sorrow because um in a week's time um
that judgment will be made so I don't
want to think think of we've just got to
deal with it and it's more I'm thinking
I'm more about the Optics and public
opinion but we might not have a choice
right no you might not the choice might
not be yours but right now you have a
choice about how you view that and it
seems to me you do regret it you do
understand why people haven't liked the
fact you use the foundation name to
process this application and then put a
bar pooling it might go some way to
dissipate the criticism to say
regardless of what the council the side
we understand now the anger that's
created and we're going to get rid of
that pool we're going to make it more of
what the rest of this building is a
genuine Museum to your father yeah I I
think if if it goes against us then
we've got to look at the
whole the whole building and see you
know I mean how we could redesign it
because obviously the the facilities are
out there but why don't you just say
Colin we're going to get rid of the
pool well we have we we have to see what
happens but the only op you don't know
it's your pool yeah you can be ordered
to raise it all yeah which which might
happen which is the only but right now
for the purposes of this interview given
that you accept it was a mistake I would
offer you the chance to say regardless
we're going to get rid of it so we'll
have to honestly Piers we will have to
look at how we can redesign the building
and the roof structure to why are you
reluctant to say you'll get rid of it
well because we haven't looked at that
as an option because at the moment it's
a black and white situation of either
all and we haven't looked at in order to
redesign it we'll have to look at how I
would say if I'm watching this andah I'm
like come on you know everybody hates
that pool you know why they hate it you
know really you shouldn't have done it
the way you did it you know you
shouldn't have used the foundation's
name to do this just we understand that
and we're going to get rid of it because
we believe there should be a legacy to
your father and we know that that is
what's caused a lot of anger and if we
had options that would definitely be one
of them well that it's always an option
you can just get rid of it no it's not
because our when we go to appeal it's
keep it or or tear it all down right
there isn't a but even if you get
allowed to keep it I would say get rid
of it well if we are allowed to keep it
we will we will talk about what we're
allowed to do if you want to keep it in
light of all the it may be absolutely
one of the conditions I understand that
but I'm not talking about the council
decide I'm talking about do you actually
want to keep it now I given all the
aggravation it's caused and given to me
is pretty
indefensible given what your plan was
for this building that's really the
point I'm making should you not just say
we get it it's wrong we didn't think
this through properly and we're going to
get rid of it you have a chance now
before anybody else makes that decision
for you if you want to do that I think
we would sit down and decide what we
want to do I the actual pool itself I I
the thing that is has made people angry
and the reason and we know we did this
wrong is we covered it we built over it
and the compromised solution of course
is to have it just in sit you outside
without being covered well well to be
clear the Charities trustees said at no
time were the Captain Tom foundation's
independent trustees aware of planning
permissions made by Mr and Mrs Ingram
Moore reporting to be in the
foundation's name had they been aware of
any applications the independent
trustees would not have authorized them
so it's not quite as straightforward as
that they wouldn't have authorized them
if they' known and you were using the
foundation name for the planning
permission
application and that's why I simply come
back to when I walked around here I feel
my heart swell
about this amazing guy and I love what
you've begun to do here as a tribute to
him and I could imagine people wanting
to come and see
it but when I first walk in the first
thing I see is a luxurious barpool
that's got nothing to do with Captain
Tom at
all and yet you use the Captain Tom
Foundation name to get it and that's why
I'm
surprised that given I've asked this a
few times now you don't just say
actually we get it that's going to go
regardless of whatever the council
says so I'll give you one last chance
then know we'll move on but it's I think
it's important I think though that I
can't possibly answer that before we as
a family would sit down and discuss it
what do you think George as my mom said
earlier my granddad really wanted to
walk in the pool sure but he he can't
but other people can yeah and that's the
and and the whole part of this
application is that the community peace
m and uh we've had that Community piece
at the heart of it and and that's why I
try really hard not to react um
negatively to this because the purpose
of the building is to allow the
community to enjoy it and that was the
heart and soul behind this and it's not
that this is a museum but our whole
purpose was that my father couldn't walk
in that amazing resistance pool which in
the end is a 5 m x 2 m pool
but other people can um part of the
Aging population can we have a Pilates
teacher who's waiting for this space to
be authorized so she can do Pilates
classes for our aging population so
until those dreams are dead until we've
been told you can't do any and see again
I don't want to be cynical but I don't
think that was the main motivation for
that pull I think the main motivation
was you wanted a nice barp as a family
to use yourself of course but part of I
don't think it's really about whether
other old people are going to come in
and use it I think you guys wanted to
use it yourselves and that's fair enough
right you're perly entitled to spend
your money however you want to spend it
by the way right if it's your money that
pay for all this it's your call yes this
is not a legal thing right this is just
a I guess it's a moral thing it's
whether you feel comfortable given the
furor that the first thing people come
into when they come into the Captain Tom
Foundation Building is a spar pool that
is just a luxurious item I I think just
to correct that this now is not the
Captain Tom Foundation Building it was
done in error on the first application
on the second application it's called
the Captain Tom and it's called the what
Captain Tom building because it's our
Legacy it doesn't have well well it's
actually because I know Colin to be fair
it was the the foundation trustees
weren't even aware of the first
application so you weren't you weren't
able to use it in the second one no but
we didn't anyway so we've but that but
that's why you didn't use it no it
wasn't actually because that it was
already in 12 months before before so we
corrected we we found out we' done that
we realized we'd done it and we
corrected it so it's was called Captain
Tom building Captain Tom lived in this
area in this building in our grounds and
it was called the Captain Tom building
why do you care so much about the sparle
that you're prepared to damage your
reputations going forward just through
it seems to me slight I I might be wrong
but a slight sort of well so you where
keep it mentality which I can understand
because of the attacks you've had but
wouldn't it just be better for the
Optics to get rid of the thing it might
be but we have to look at the design the
design of the building was set up in
such a way so we and we just we don't
want to commit to it um Hannah you got
criticized going to wimbl tennis oh yes
um and I remember watching this live
actually you were on Cent call and your
father's name got mentioned and uh you
stood up that you're encouraged to by
one of the Wimbledon officials stand up
and you took the Applause of the crowd
and in the moment it probably seemed
like a very nice moment for you but
within hours you were getting hammered
on social media because people are say
well you're not Captain Tom what are you
doing there on your own at the center
Court why are you taking the Applause of
the crowd and so on you know what people
said how did you feel when you read that
reaction it was extraordinary we were
invited colonized as part of that Legacy
and of the recognition that of the
family doing so much to support my
father to raise that 40 million of
course if he'd been alive I would have
probably gone with him um but instead we
were invited um the two of us I had
never an intention to stand up why would
I want to do that um but I was not
encouraged I was told to because the
Applause who was it that told you that
um I can't remember I think it was a
chair I think it might have been um and
I would never have stood up but he he'd
said you must stand up and people were
waving and shouting and everything that
um how do I stay silent I feel that was
unfair on me was all right I felt that
was unfair I think The Spar pool
criticism is Justified I think that to
me felt unfair you're representing your
dad you've been right center Station the
whole time you the crowd applauded very
warmly
right so they clearly didn't have a
problem with you being there and you
stood up and you thanked them and that
was it was a nice moment I thought um
well it was amazing and of course if
someone's waving how I thought it was so
rude not to wave back that's all that I
did let's talk about the when you become
CEO of the
foundation and you put
forward that you want to be paid I think
originally it was going to be three days
a week and you'd be paid £65,000 a year
and then there's an application to
increase that to full-time job 100,000 a
year although there is a range up to
£150,000 and you were taking advice from
people about the kind of range for a CEO
of this kind of foundation what they
might get is that an accurate
representation of what happened the
independent trustees came to me and said
would I be prepared to do that job and
and I said yes I would be prepared to
they went away and benched marked salary
I didn't ask for anything did you feel
any quals about taking a job which would
involve you being
paid effectively I guess from public
donations because that finances the
foundation right that because you were
his daughter actually and maybe with
hindsight this is the the question
whether it would have been much easier
for you not to have taken that job to
really interesting isn't it because at
the time it felt like the only thing to
do um because without the injection from
the family what was it going to become
we had this incredible Legacy our desire
as a family is to ensure that Legacy
gives the greatest positive social
impact that it can do you know in
hindsight I wish I'd never done it um
but the foundation would have been much
worse off for it the problem is that
what's come since has practically
destroyed it but I I think all those
things hindsight is wonderful we can all
look back and think maybe we should have
done things when the when the charity
commission refused the foundation to let
you be paid a salary of 100,000 saying
it was neither reasonable nor Justified
that must have been a pretty difficult
moment for you but I wasn't part of that
discussion that was the independent
trustees no when you heard they were
refusing to let you be paid it yes you
must have known this is going to be a
story it's going to make me look bad
right it's going to look like I'm trying
to get underground running my father's
foundation and I've now had that salary
rejected for being unreasonable
unjustified it just doesn't forget the
fact that I know you right when I first
saw that I went ouch that doesn't look
good only those discussions was I was I
was never part of that 100 range
whatever it was I only was offered what
I was offered right but you accepted
that but I accepted what I
off I never ever thought that those
discussions would make it into the
public Arena ever because they were
private discussions your salary was
always going to be a public public
record yeah but but never any of the
discussions and the argument was that
you had no experience that justifi that
kind of salary running a huge Foundation
as chief executive officer I get the
personal part of your thinking that well
who else could have done it in your
dad's name in the way that you would
know because you knew him so well I get
that but I think that to expect a salary
of £100,000 of public money when you're
his daughter then it it looks bad it
looks bad it's like here's Hannah she
she wants 100,000 a year for a job she's
not really qualified to do in terms of
experience at all if you'd had a
background of running Charities it's far
more Justified but you didn't and so the
public well hang on a second she's
getting 100 Grand of our money to do
this firstly I was never offered 100,000
I was offered what they offered me in
the end which was not 100,000 well in
the end they did a deal to pay 85
because that was what the charity
commission prepared to accept yes you
did accept 100,000 originally because
that was put forward to the charity
commission I didn't ever accept a
100,000 well that's what they put
forward yeah but and I didn't know they
were going to offer me 100 I wasn't part
of that discussion those discussions are
between the trustees and the charity
commission not me but you would have
accepted whatever salary they paid you
right probably yes yeah it's a kind of
move Point well maybe it is the charity
commission said you can only pay a
maximum of 85,000 I think you went on
that on a rolling thre Monon scenario
while you found somebody else exactly um
I mean so you said with hindsight you
wouldn't have taken that job because it
just pulled more anro on your head right
yeah I think
um in the end I was asked to do a job
for all the right reasons and because I
do have uh knowledge of Global business
from my from my
past and you you're like a marketing
director at sales sales and distribution
yes some for some big Brands yeah so I
wasn't without knowledge and I knew and
we believed as a family that um I could
put the charity on the map and um and
and you know what I did do a really good
job while I was there I got it to the
point that it had purpose and it had VIs
vision and it knew where it was going
but in hindsight no I should have said
no I'm not doing it the commission
identified potential concerns about
payments of consultancy fees and
payments to family companies in your
first year of accounts but they then
said they were satisfied these specific
payments were reasonable urement for
expenses incurred by the companies in
the formation of a charity um what
raised eyebrows was there were total
cost of I think it was £
55,78426 I guess it's again the Optics
right given that it's your management
company would it have been better with
hindsight not to have had any money come
from the foundation public money to your
management company regardless of how
legitimate the expense is if if there
had been a mechanism to do that then yes
it would have been a much more
preferable situation actually for both
sides because that you know it proved
difficult for Matrix as well you know
they weren't our staff we just paid the
money and passed it on pound for pound
to to the charity to be clear neither of
you have ever made any money directly
from the foundation for personal gain
not a penny no there's nothing that's
like that no and as we've said
um we have never been so I am a family
trustee um and I became a family trustee
12 months after the original charity was
set
up I'm a charted accountant and I have
been very specific I was very specific
right from day one that I had absolutely
no access to the bank account I had no
signing powers I've never seen a
checkbook never mind uh made any
payments I'm not able to make any
payments I'm not an authorized person
Hannah during her role in three months
in theory was able to authorize payments
but she never did and we were very clear
that that's not something we should do
so the independent trustees had sole
discretion as to who they paid how it
was paid and when it was paid we have
never ever had a penny out of that
[Music]
welcome back to PBG our sensus shortly
before the Captain Tom Foundation was
launched Hannah and Colin set up a
private company called Club Nook limited
that company made applications for
trademarks related to S Tom's name and
his image the charity commission says
that could have generated a significant
profit for the company and they're
looking into whether that's appropriate
in my next part of my interview the
family revealed exclusively how the
company has made its money and it's a
lot of money and why they believe it's
unrelated to a Charity's
work CL makes £89,000 in its first year
and after creditors were paid it was
left with just under half a million
pound that was from the company accounts
and this uh company was basically
licensing trademark registered names of
products including beer Spirits greting
cards clothing calendars biscuits and so
on that's that's potentially potentially
so where did that money come
from the money came from exactly that
from from from products not from
products it came from uh in using his
intellectual property right but where
did the actual Revenue come from as a as
a private company but what was the
revenue from from from those from his
assets from his Family Trust what you
mean from and from appearances that he
made and other things where he was where
he was occasionally paid for the for
those
activities right so Hannah were you
involved in this in the club not
business so because you were asked by
the times where the money had come from
and you you didn't
answer just to clarify what that income
that 800,000 what can you be more
specific it's it's not something that we
want to talk about because it's at the
end of the day it's our our private a
lot of money it's a lot of money but we
also have SE several businesses and I
think that we shouldn't but this one was
set up
specifically to trademark your father's
name prodct and and other business and
other business opportunities right and
but where is that money gone but those
are not all entirely related to Captain
Tom they're other businesses that we
have you know the reason I'm asking is
obvious is that people will think that
you've used your father's name in club
limited to trademark products and you've
kept the
money is that true no I'm presuming all
the revenue that came into that has come
from trademark products that why said
not all some um some it has what
percentage well I don't know I could say
you you are the two aren't you the two
directors the majority of it the
majority of it so the majority of the
800,000 has come from selling trademark
products
products associated with his name yeah
right yeah because that's the whole
point of the company right so what's
happened to that
money it has been it has been used you
know some of it was used to look after
Tom looked after
security um and and trying to look to
how we can build that in the
future right but you've kept most of it
I
guess yeah yeah it's it's private income
right so this that for me is another
problem another red flag I got to be
honest CU I guess that was what the
actual answer was going to be and the
public are going to think hang on a
second the family has set up this
company called Club not limited to
trademark the Captain Tom name to sell
products beers Spirits greeding cars and
so on and they've kept the cash why are
the Charities not getting the cash my
father was part of all of those
discussions M and that company is there
in its Essence to to protect him that's
why it was there and also from his
perspective that we had a right to live
and to to to live as well as we could
live we were hard workers and we are not
shers we um have we put everything in to
everything and we're recompensed and I
think that's fair I £800,000 by fogging
off Captain Tom beer and spirits and
biscuit I think you're misleading there
that that's an as that was potentially
an aspiration to that we got to remember
the company made
89,000 that didn't have any public
donated money so that was not public
donation was the public buying the
products
the not necessarily okay but what I
would say is I mean Hannah you said to
the times Club knook is not profited
from branded merchandise and memorabilia
Club knook has not been paid by the
foundation for use of its trademarks
Club NOS revenues been generated by
other activities I mean that's just not
true is it Club Lo has profited heavily
from branded merchandise and
memorabilia that statement wasn't
correct yeah it is it is correct it's
not because the club has profited to
this tune of net 500,000 from branded
merchandise it's from products that hold
his name
right but it's not but that's branded
product isn't it I mean you you know
that's branded
product this not the word for it is it I
think this is a this is a a really
[Music]
um I think it's a really unfair um line
of questioning because because these are
businesses that we run they are
protecting my father's name he allowed
his name to be used in the charity um
for for charitable purposes that was it
anything else St this is not a
charitable purpose no and when you said
to the times that club hadn't profited
from branded merchandise that's not true
it made £89,000 in its first year from
branded merchandise can we just stop and
that's that's not about protecting it's
not about protecting can we just stop
for a second yeah this is we can we just
can we stop for a second sure and stop
filming because this is really unfair so
what what's unfair no so let let us
explain off off camera I'd rather do it
on camera no no no no if it's on camera
we're not doing an interview the
interview was dramatically stopped and
we had a lengthy off the record
conversation during the course of this
Hannah and Colin revealed where the
revenue had actually come from and we
agreed to go back on the record so Colin
here's what I need to establish because
this has been the issue which people
have been uh I think rightly concerned
about which is all this money this
£89,000 in the first year that club Nook
limited raised in Revenue where did that
come from because the belief is it came
from Captain Tom themed merchandise is
that the case no that that the money
hasn't come from merchandise the bulk of
that money the vast majority of that
money came from the three books that he
wrote um with penguin Random House the
Captain Tom wrote the the Captain Tom
wrote including one was a big runaway
number one best yeah so tomorrow will be
a good day which is his autobiography
which is about his life um and what
percentage of the club money was from
those books 95% of it so the vast
majority yeah was there any other
merchandise theme
product no never any no so Club not
never made any revenue from Captain Tom
theme merchandise outside of these books
no so Hannah the question I guess about
the books
is people will say well the books are
based on his Fame which came from the
charity walks why is that money not gone
to
charity these um were my father's books
and and it was honestly such a joy for
him to write them but they were his
books
they um the deal was done he had an
agent and the agent um and he worked on
that deal they were Captain Tom's books
and his wishes were that that money was
that that money would sit in club Nook
and in the end um you to keep yes he
said that specifically to you
specifically was there anything on any
of the books that referred to the
Captain Tom Foundation absolutely not
was there anything in the contracts that
referred to Captain foundation so there
was never any agreement by you on behalf
of your father with these book deals
that any of that money would go to
charity absolutely not and remember that
he wrote these books um he started
writing them fairly early on um just as
the walk had finished and they were all
signed off he'd finished them by the
June of
2020 um there they were never anything
to do with the
charity what will you say to people
who'll say you shouldn't have kept that
money that it should have all gone to
the Char that these books were based on
Captain Tom it's the public are buying
the books it should all have gone to
Charlie what will you say to those but
they were my father's books um he wrote
them and he decided what to do with the
income from them it was his wishes not
not ours he made the decision about the
things that he did we um didn't act for
him Colin I mean people will criticize
this you know know that but are you
comfortable looking back would you do
the same thing again given all the
attention that's now been put on you as
a family all the
criticism would you if you had your time
again keep that money yes you know they
were it was his money his income and
just because the charity happened to be
called Captain Tom Foundation doesn't
mean that his assets are all suddenly be
owned by the Char it and I think you
know one of the things we've thought
about quite a lot is probably in
hindsight calling the foundation Captain
Tom foundation and allowing his name to
be used in that especially as a living
person um was the wrong thing to do and
we probably you know that advice should
have come forward to us at the beginning
but it didn't and you know we've we've
come to regret it um and been associated
with the foundation and suddenly
everything is associated with the
foundation which is incorrect there will
be people who say that you shouldn't as
a family have made any money off the
back of your father including the books
including everything right what do you
say to those people Hannah but they were
his books they he might have lived for
another four or five years and that
wasn't income we took from him it was
income from his books that he loved to
write and and I suppose there'll always
be criticism we it we can't do right for
doing wrong in the end they were his and
if he was sitting here today he'd say
yes P that's exactly what we talked
about we're not making up what he wanted
he was alive um when that book deal
happened we didn't make the decisions
for him he made
them since I recorded this interview we'
discovered a statement on the Charity's
website and a tweet from Captain Tom's
account which do imply that the books
could support the foundation the
Charities mentioned in one of the books
and the prologue to his autobiography
says this astonishingly at my age with
the offer to write this Memoir I've also
been given the chance to raise even more
money for the charitable Foundation now
established in my name two more books
were published after his death in 2021
one offering a one pound donation to the
foundation for each book sold and
whether any of this broke any rules will
ultimately be for the charity commission
to
decide
[Music]
Hannah let me ask you about another
thing which caused criticism this is
where you've appeared at award
ceremonies the Virgin Media O2 Captain
Tom Foundation connector Awards which
included the name of the charity and the
Charity's logo on its award Parks you
were at the time the interim chief
executive uh of the foundation but your
fee wasn't paid to the foundation but to
The Matrix Group is that correct yes and
how much were you paid for these Awards
um well the charity got a donation and I
was paid £18,000 for that once only or
was it once so you were paid
£18,000 and how much did the charity get
£2,000
2,000 the criticism again is obvious
which is that you shouldn't have been
paid this is your father's Foundation
Award and set up in his name you're the
foundation chief executive why are you
getting paid £18,000 and keeping £16,000
of it what do you say to that well that
relationship with Virgin Media started
way back in 2020 where my father was
paid to uh be a judge um and judges are
often paid um was he paid yes and he
kept that money yes and that it wasn't
award ceremonies it was a community
Awards so the first one I and I was
doing it with him because of course he
couldn't do it by himself um they were
about awarding a community um Awards
with Virgin Media that relationship
continued and they asked me to keep
working with
them by the time we evolved it they were
now Virgin Media row to and all of those
discussions were happening even before I
was imagining being interim CEO so those
plans were already did you understand
why people I do and do you wish you
hadn't taken the money now I think in
hindsight what I should have done is
stalled that relationship either to
afterwards or just given the money to
the to the foundation yeah you were the
chief executive of the foundation the
the award was for your father right well
they were the Captain Tom
Awards I worked with Virgin Media to
ensure that the charity got some money
and recognition because I knew that they
would get huge recognition through
social media um and hopefully real
engagement with the Char
for looking at these for for seeing how
the charity was becoming involved in
their War all of which I think is
completely valid and and good right just
for the record I think they're excellent
Awards the only question is whether you
should have pocketed the cash I mean I
again you know I would say that looking
at that it doesn't look good you know
you're the chief executive of the
foundation the foundation awards are in
your father's name to keep £16,000 just
for turning up and presenting a few
Awards seems to me to be
the wrong thing to do do you do you
think that I think that it's all very
easy to look back and think I should
have made different decisions but I
hadn't planned on being the CEO and I
also only knew that I would I was only
ever there for 3 months at a time so I
didn't know if I would have employment
past those three months and I'm not in a
position where I can not work so for me
when we were planning all those dates
they may well have fallen in a period of
time when I wasn't the CEO that but
that's how it landed and and I
absolutely ensured that the charity got
a donation once you knew you were CEO
when you turned up at the awards and you
knew you were getting the money wouldn't
the better thing to have been to just
give it all to the foundation I think
the better thing to have done would have
been to push those Awards to outside
that period of time because I was only
ever going to be there for nine months
so I should have just pushed them um
forward or or or brought them in advance
but people will hear that and go so you
just wanted the money whereas actually
wouldn't I mean I don't want to put
words in your mouth but for you to look
back and say actually I shouldn't have
taken that money it was wrong I might be
a better answer I mean I don't tell you
how to answer these questions because
I'm the one asking them but it makes it
sound like that that answer makes it
sound like he just wanted the cash but I
think the reality is that I have to work
for a living and um th that relationship
with them was an ongoing relationship
and you were being paid £85,000 a year
for that job well to to be CEO of the
Captain Tom Foundation this were the
Captain Tom Foundation Awards well not
to be too pedantic but I was never gain
to earn 80 because I could never have
been there for a whole year no
understand but that was the prata
rolling three Monon annual deal right
and look absolutely in hindsight the two
things should have been separated the
the two things should have been
separated but that's not how it landed
and um that it was done with love and
with trying to ensure that the community
benefit benefited and the Captain Tom
Foundation benefited and yes I got paid
when when BBC News I asked you about
this you said via email you are awful
it's a total lie that was your first
response you then you then said that um
six minutes later you added apologies
that reply was for a scam who's been
creating habit which is absolutely true
which is true but did you did you
actually give them any clarification
about the money why why why were you
reluctant to because I I think that we
were being I probably received well many
many many emails trying to demand
information and we genuinely wanted to
make sure that when we do talk that we
talk on our terms and that we're um
we're saying it how it is and I didn't
think that was the right place I can see
that this has had a very traumatic
effect on you the whole thing yeah the
whole thing and the hatred is brought
the abuse it's brought to you the
questioning of your
integrity the the diminishing as some
would say the reputation of your father
must be particularly terrible hurtful I
can see the effect it's had on yeah and
and and I I mean let me just pick up
with Han that I
mean articulate how it's been for you I
mean utterly devastating to think that
we have something that we thought could
make a global positive impact to be
devastated overnight because of course
when everything's positive and good
everyone wants to associate with you and
then when there's just a flicker of
Doubt all the people who are busy who
were engaging with us left literally
left it took a little bit longer for
things to flick into our business life
but suddenly contracts weren't being
renewed the foundation is probably never
able to recover from the foundation the
foundation is not able to recover the
trustees
don't want to close it you know and I
come back to what it's done to Hannah in
particular I mean she has been extremely
ill and from the stress from the stress
extremely ill and we all have what's
your overriding message to to the world
because the world followed this
story I
think that we as a family will we've
ever ever ever wanted to do was ensure
that my father's um Legacy has the
greatest possible positive impact on
society wherever that is and we felt
that we were really close to being able
to do it um and that has been taken away
and yes of course it's we're all judged
on hindsight um but what we have to
remember is where we were and how we
were making decisions was in a different
time we were operating at a th000 miles
an hour nothing ever felt that we had
any time or calm Essence to make
decisions so of course we can look back
and say some of those things should have
been done differently but I think give
us some credit for being human and that
we weren't an extraordinary family we're
just a family trying to do our best in
the circumstances we were plunged into
so of course we can look back and think
optically they that may look look not
look right but it was was never our
intent to do anything other than work
with my father's Legacy to to give as
much as we could to the world and that
allows people far beyond my father's
lifetime or ours that allows people to
touch this incredible what would he be
thinking now looking down on what's been
happening to you well he would sit here
with us and say um I'm with them we
haven't been that family who's um tried
to take his legacy and make it for our
own gain we're trying our best we've
tried our best to do the right thing and
sometimes it's turned out it wasn't but
not through intent Benji what how have
you felt as your mom's boy you're 19 it
is just utterly devastating and to see
the impact has had on her and you know
people can have opinions that is up to
them but what what you cannot stand is
threats and abuse that are just vile and
the the difficulty she to go through
watching that as a as a son in
particular he's been actually
devastating I mean just to see your mom
now tearing up again but Absol I mean
there's been times there's been genuine
times where I don't think she's known if
she could go on and I've sat there and
thought that as well but the the utter
mental drain that it's caused us have
you felt that way have you felt like
ending it all well no I'm my father's
daughter at the end of the day um but it
has been totally
devastating and
and it's all very well say well this is
what we try to do one of the other
really important things is we want to
continue to do you know we absolutely
believe in this in a world without agism
we absolutely believe that Tom's Legacy
needs to do something going forward and
needs is a very important thing that we
need to keep going you know in the world
George what's it been like for you I
mean no young girl wants to see her mom
like this I know she's always trying to
put on a smile to make sure I don't
really know that much but I know it's
really draining for them all the time
every single day even at night I know
that they're going to wake up with a
smile even if it if they're really
draining inside has it been tough for
you tough for seeing my parents and
family getting hate and abuse from
people inside the social media makes me
don't want to make go on social media
well listen thank you for sharing your
time with me a lot of time you took all
the questions you said you would things
it's important you did people can make
their own minds up it's extremely tough
clearly I can see from your reaction and
I'm I'm sorry to see you like this all
of
you no thank you thank you thank you
appreciate time thank
you